Thrift store finds at my local thrift store.
First up, we have this tapestry,
and then we have this radio slash turntable.
Guys, I might go back for this next week
because it's just too good to pass up for only 50 bucks.
My husband wanted this book,
so we got that.
I'm also obsessed with anything geese
decor related. Lately.
I would like to start a gallery wall in my living room,
and I just. I don't know.
There's just something about that painting that I liked.
This came home with me for sure
because it's small and cute.
Passed on this,
but it was an excellent condition.
And of course,
I always have to survey all the quilts.
I love all of them.
This gun sacks dress haunts me each time I come here.
I need to buy it.
I got my daughter this little people airplane.
And then I also got towels to cut up and make
for replacing our paper towels.